it's time for the launching horoscope a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour a presentation of the
lawn gene which nor wats company maker
of launching the world's most honored
wat and wit nor distinguished companion
to the world honored lon gene good
evening this is frank night may i
introduce mr. william bradford huie
noted author and analyst and
editor-in-chief of the launch in chrono
scope and mr. Hardy Burke noted author
and correspondent our distinguished
guest for this evening is dr. AE L
kubovich former israeli minister to
Czechoslovakia and Poland dr. bubay our
viewers tonight are very much interested
sir and what's going on and the Russian
satellite countries as regards the Jews
and you with your long experience to
satellite nations in satellite nations
are peculiarly well qualified to give us
that information you were ambassador to
Czechoslovakia and I believe after you
had left there a Russian government in
effect asked the Israeli government not
to send you back now sir specifically
when did you leave Czechoslovakia I left
Czechoslovakia November the 28th 2d
after the end of this last trial that's
just two months ago tumor answer how
long had you been there before you left
well I first want to state that I was
minister to Czechoslovakia into Poland
and I spend their 17 months and so you
were there 17 months you were there
during the Frog trials you observed the
rise of anti-semitism and
now you have been away from
Czechoslovakia just two months that's
right doctor is there pronounced rise of
anti-semitism as you saw it there well
there is no doubt that the slansky trial
was an expression of anti-semitism I see
Sir now can you tell us something sir as
to the extent of anti-semitism in
Czechoslovakia specifically are the Jews
living are they afraid the Jews who are
now in Czechoslovakia do they live in
terror i would say that since the arrest
of slansky and the purge of jewish
officials which was followed by an
ouster of a number of jews from their
economic positions the jews have the
definite impression that this is a
regime directed against them that's Jews
as Jews not Jews as political fig not at
all at all is there any difference
between what's going on in Poland and
Czechoslovakia the Polish regime has
shown more stability as far as his
composition is concerned that the
Czechoslovak regime I mean as far as his
ruling class is concerned but there has
remained in Poland among the Polish
population a very deep-seated
anti-semitism and those Jews who
remained in Poland remain because they
could not emigrate in time to Israel
feel that they are in a very dangerous
situation doctor why do if there is this
anti-semitic feeling there and Poland
why do they want to keep the Jewish
people in fulham why don't they let them
leave if they don't like them I mean
eventually I there you know that the
Soviet Union as well as all the
satellite countries are in principle or
post to emigration and they permit it
the immigration of Jews for a certain
period immediately following the war
while there was still a feeling of guilt
still the feeling that the Jews after
what had happened during the war at a
terrible extermination during the war
were entitled to into revealed their
lives in a home of their own well under
dr. do you see any comparison between
the Hitler's persecution of the Jews and
what Stalin is doing today is there any
comparison there i would say that
anti-semitism is always a mean in
instrument for certain bigger purposes
and in this respect i would say there is
some identity between all kinds of other
cemeteries well some similarity and the
Jews are being made a scapegoat you need
a scapegoat I see well the important
thing that you've said now sir is that
you are not as an observer of the
situation you make a difference between
what's going on in various satellite
nations you don't apply a general
statement to what's going on there sir
is that correct I would I would say that
the recent developments make us very
anxious because if one could build your
opinion that the Brock trial was distant
for Czechoslovak purposes in order to
find the scapegoat for the economic
difficulties of Czechoslovakia to give
the people an explanation why from the
very high standard of living they have
known at war their standard of living
now is so low after what we have seen in
eastern Germany and after the indictment
of the physicians in Moscow you have
every reason to be very anxious and to
see there the symptom of a general
development pursuing this question a
little follow-up
that mystery raise doctor you mentioned
a difference of degree in the treatment
of the Jewish people in Czechoslovakia
and in Poland now to your knowledge is
that difference also a difference of
degree in the Soviet Union itself I mean
within Russia eight so how would you
have any knowledge of that that
difference of degree again hey I would
not like to speak of the past because
the fate of the Jews in the Soviet Union
has passed through great a great number
of faiths what I would like to state is
that we are witness now of a very very
disturbing development I see well sir
now can you explain to our viewers why
this is happening your understanding of
Soviet techniques is this number one is
it aimed that we've heard that it's a
tactic for the Middle East that it is a
tactic by which the Soviet Union hopes
to attract support among the Arabs would
you say that that's one of the reasons
why this is being done well i would like
to distinguish between various reasons
then i would like you to understand that
a trial like the proc trial is not
destined to administer justice it has a
great number of purposes it's a it's
attacked it is a tactic it's a method
its emitter to achieve political
purposes it's also a method to
indoctrinate the masses as well as the
lead us now let us take a few purposes
but the proc dryer for instance was had
one of the purposes of the proc trial
was to convince the Czechoslovak people
that the present leaders are real checks
and real Slovak they are real Patriots
now this is
line which we will develop in all the
satellite countries because it's very
important to convince the population
that their governments are real national
governments of course there are wider
implications are more general purpose
and I would say as far as the Soviet
Union is concerned that there is no
doubt that this method is destined at
the wind of friendship of those are the
of those who are or maybe the enemies of
Israel and of the Jewish people in view
of all of this dr. why is it that the
government of Israel realizing that
there is this great wave of any Jewish
propaganda and cinema that's been set up
behind there and curtain why is it that
do they continue to recognize the Soviet
Union well I don't see any purpose in
withdrawing our representations from the
various countries Israel is not the only
country which has been the object of
very violent attacks and if I may say
you're referring to the right of slaves
I have seen the treatment for instance
of American diplomats and I am sure a
dr.s I have considered it an act of
courage on the part of the American
diplomats it to maintain their contacts
in their connections in order and to
serve a higher purpose well now sir our
viewers will be particularly interested
and what Israel as a state expects to do
about this latest development now sir do
you think that it will be Israeli policy
to try to bring as many of these people
to Israel as possible there is no doubt
that this will be our policy and keep
the Soviet Union and if
satellite countries could assert in the
past that they're there Jews didn't want
to immigrate that after all there were
citizens with full rights and now that
the Jews are under such attacks I think
that we are entitled to tell them let
our people go we are willing to accept
these Cosmopolitan's we are willing to
accept the so-called science this means
that certainly many many more Jews if
you're successful in this many many more
Jews will be brought into Israel itself
yes this is our intention this is our
determination well sir that comes down
to money and that there have been
several efforts to sell Israeli bonds in
the United States now are you in the
United States in connection with that
Bart with a bond Drive I mean connection
with this dry because we have to
strengthen Israel economically in order
to permit it to absorb the many
immigrants which we want to move you
want to bring to Israel and that can
only be done without side economic aid
only let us hit me well I'm sure that
our viewers have appreciated these
expressions if you're a certain thank
you for being with us the opinions that
you heard our speakers express tonight
have been entirely there oh the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching pronto scope was mister
william bradford huie and mr. Hardy
burnt our distinguished guest was dr.
REE el cubo p former israeli minister to
Czechoslovakia and Poland